it can be hard to tell when your
physical symptoms are a sign of
something serious in their new book am i
dying a complete guide to your symptoms
and what to do next doctors Christopher
Kelly and Mark Eisenberg break down when
to relax when to call your doctor when
to go to the ER they are cardiologist at
New York Presbyterian Columbia
University Medical Center and they join
us here at the table thank you good
morning good morning I think the first
question you both have to answer is how
are you better than dr. Google please I
think if you go online that answer will
be apparent very quickly you know if you
look up any symptom online within a few
seconds you're gonna convince yourself
that you have cancer that you're having
a heart attack that death is gonna
happen any second now
so alarm is not something you counsel I
guess no you know despite the very loud
title we actually most of the time in
this book offer people reassurance and
help them understand that their symptoms
are probably not a big deal but in rare
cases which we focus on - they should
seek medical help yeah sometimes it does
matter we saw the Seinfeld clip which is
very funny but chest pain can be the
sign of something serious when when is
it something serious right you pay
attention of course so like George when
most people have chest pain they think
they're having a heart attack and in
fact right now this week between
Christmas and New Year is the number one
time in the year to have a heart attack
but there's a lot of causes of chest
pain that then aren't heart attacks so
for example if you're getting a jump on
your New Year's resolution going to the
gym more often and you pull a muscle in
your chest you know if you move your
body around or raise your arm and that
causes chest pain that's probably
nothing to worry but the serious sign is
what what's the you should go - yeah so
if you have pressure in your chest like
somebody's sitting on your chest and
it's not going away after a few minutes
and maybe it's going up your neck or
down your arm
maybe you're also feeling a little short
of breath that's definitely a red flag
and someone should go to the emergency
room immediately for that I love how
your book is organized you have
different symptoms and you basically
have three levels okay if you're
experiencing this chill out if you're
experiencing this you might want to call
a doctor if and if it's these symptoms
you may want to go to the ER I read the
forgetfulness chapter because that's
something I struggle with I was told to
relax by your book thank you good what
about other things like sore throats
which are really so again that's what
our book tries to differentiate we take
a symptom and we try to help people come
up with a plan
whether they should be weird
whether they should make a doctor's
appointment or whether they should go to
the emergency room so a lot of people
wake up every morning with a sore throat
and it goes away in the next hour or two
that could just be dry air and you need
a humidifier but if you have a really
bad sore throat for a day or two and you
take your cellphone and you take a
picture of the inside your tonsils and
you see some white you know exudate sore
spots that could be strep and then you
need to make a doctor's appointment we
should go through a couple more here I
mean back pain right celebrating its
100th anniversary of the excuse for not
doing anything yes when do you know when
back pain is a real serious issue and
when it's just something to get you out
of taking the garbage on yeah so I have
back pain at all times I have three
little kids at home on my feet all day
at the hospital you know if you have
back pain and it's been there for less
than two or three weeks and it gets
better with pain medicines then that's
really something that you should
probably just wade out but you know back
pain that is associated with like a
burning sensation on one side of your
back for example that could actually be
shingles which is very common in people
over 50 if you have back pain and you
have a rather quick loss of strength or
sensation in one of your legs that's
actually an emergency you need to go to
the ER immediately for that because that
could indicate that the nerves in your
back or the spinal cord are compromised
by whatever's causing your back pain you
said you know the back pain is always
there I'll say sleepiness and being
tired is always there for me but mark
when is yeah for most of us but when is
that a more serious sign well it could
be a very serious sign if you're
fatigued or tired all day and you're
urinating a lot you could actually have
diabetes also if you're very tired and
you're also gaining weight and have
constipation and you're cold and it's
the middle of summer you could actually
have a thyroid abnormality and you need
to go to the doctor and get it checked
out so it seems the point it's multiple
symptoms together it often means that it
will that's how that's how we try to
differentiate between how serious
something is we take a symptom like leg
swelling or fatigue or forgetfulness and
we ask if they're having other
associated symptoms and that's how you
as a doctor or nurse when you see a
patient that's how you try to
differentiate how serious we're always
looking for patterns right so it's like
you have this one symptom what sort of
template does it fit into right and
that's how we get closer to the answer
are you hoping to reduce ER visits with
this book because that's one of the
biggest problems in the healthcare
system a lot of people don't get their
regular checkups they go to the ER that
costs a lot of money yeah
it's a you know especially in this day
when people don't even know if they have
health insurance anymore and a lot of
people are either have no insurance or
they're underinsured or they have very
high deductibles you know they're very
nervous about going to a doctor so I
think hopefully our book will help
people decide what the next step is and
help you get out of conversations at
dinner parties 62 dr. Kelly and dr.
Eisenberg thank you so much thank you
am i dying goes on sale on Monday